allons plus loin donc dans l'entretien
ce soir avec vous dominique reynié
bienvenu merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation êtes professeur des
universités à sciences po et directeur
général de la fondation pour
l'innovation politique
faites vous partie de ceux qui
considèrent que l'état d'urgence
sanitaire n'a plus lieu d'être et qui
trouvent cela d'ailleurs même dangereux
s'il se poursuivaient bonsoir et merci
de votre invitation non en tout cas ça
c'est par principe je ne peux pas dire
cela je ne peux pas me ranger de ce côté
là parce que il ya des éléments qui ne
relève pas de ma compétence et qui
d'ailleurs sont très discutée par les
compétences eux mêmes à savoir la
question de l'état de la pandémie
sa situation en france ça semble t-il
son reflux voir sa possible disparition
mais là il ya beaucoup d'incertitude et
encore une fois c'est lié arrête objets
très singuliers que ce virus qu'on ne
connaît pas bien qui continue à se
propager beaucoup dans le monde donc ça
veut dire qu'il est vivant il n'est pas
en train de il est pas en fin de cycle
de vie
il est peut-être en train de partir ici
mais il est ailleurs donc il peut
revenir
il ya une vraie incertitude j'imagine
que le roux le fait de rouvrir les
frontières ce qui me paraît nécessaire
comme tout le monde a pour des tas de
raisons expose aussi à un retour du
virus faisait extrêmement fragile c'est
une première et il me semble que par
principe dire il faut qu'il faut arrêter
il faut revenir à la normale et une en
l'état d'urgence sanitaire basculer même
cela parce que vous savez on le voit
depuis le début on est à vous par métier
puis moi aussi sa manière par métier
aussi même si je suis pas compétent sur
ces questions de virus mais ce que l'on
voit c'est que les le comportement des
politiques dans ce sens situation et
dires de beaucoup de citoyens est assez
paradoxal puisque moi j'ai clairement
entendu des responsables politiques qui
se plaignait d'un confinement qui durait
trop longtemps puis qui ensuite se
plaignaient les mêmes d'un déconfinement
qui mettait qu'il mettait en péril les
mêmes disait qu'il ne fallait pas
laisser les enfants chez eux parce qu'il
y avait des risques d'inégalité sociale
ce qui est vrai d'ailleurs
puis quand on les a renvoyés à l'école
on a dit on renvoie les enfants à
l'école pour que les parents puissent
travailler c'est
acceptable là on dit il faut sortir une
telle agence sanitaire parce que ça
n'est plus justifiée mais s'il y avait
un rebond 1 classe terre
particulièrement important avec des
effets voire dramatique aussitôt
évidemment au fort et leurs proches sont
enfin c'est quand même
et quand on a des constitutionnalistes
comme dominique rousseau qui soupçonne
l'exécutif de vouloir garder l'état
d'urgence sanitaire pour garder la main
sur les manifestations nos libertés de
rassemblement et potentiellement voilà
regarder réprimer les manifestations
ça c'est moi je feins la magie de la
suspicion me paraît être une méthode
nous décrochons est un éminent collègue
mais la suspicion n'est pas je dirais un
point d'appui que je re que je
retiendrai mois il faut avoir des
éléments
est ce qu'il y avait ou non un danger
sanitaire est ce que nous sommes dans
une crise sanitaire de taille importante
voilà il me semble que oui ce qu'on peut
dire qu'on est en train d'en sortir on
l'espère ça a l'air de s'arranger
de là à dire que on fait avec tout ça du
théâtre ça me paraît être un risque que
je ne prendrais pas encore moins en
n'étant pas capable de trancher les
débats qui via chez les épées des
monologues même jacques toubon défenseur
des droits se pose des questions alors
qu'il vient de publier son rapport il
nous dit dans le film fun poste
fallait-il en état d'urgence
beaucoup de gens l'ont dit il existait
déjà dans le code de la santé publique
notamment depuis 2009 des dispositions
qui auraient pu permettre de prendre les
mesures nécessaires sans état d'urgence
et il alerte sur le fait que cet état
d'urgence sanitaire ne doit pas se
retrouver dans le droit commun comme
souvenez-vous ça a été le cas pour
l'état d'urgence sécurité beaucoup
pointent des risques mais là on est
encore dans la crise alors moi je vois
je vois bien ça bien sûr il faut faire
attention à tout cela on doit surveiller
sait très bien que l'institution se ceux
qui sont qui sait des autorités nous
sentîmes indépendante même parfois on
discute leur rôle mais c'est très bien
qu'elles fassent leur travail
c'est bien que les universitaires aussi
se se mobilisent ils l'ont pas fait
beaucoup d'ailleurs quand il ya eu la
crise terroristes ça m'avait frappé on a
essayé on a été assez tolérants à
l'égard de ces exceptions au droit
commun
restons vigilants mais là on a quand
même dans une situation
moi je trouve si vous voulez ce qui me
gêne je n'ai vu
dans cette crise c'est que une fois
qu'on est après on sait ce qu'il faut
faire avant mais on n'est pas avant on
est après et quand on était avant on
n'avait pas tout ça comme information
c'est vraiment un problème de
construction logique de la décision
politique
si vous décidez avec peu d'informations
ce qui est le cas quand c'est une
première vous prenez des risques
une fois qu'on prend les risques on
s'aperçoit que finalement il y en a pas
beaucoup parce qu'on a de la chance par
exemple il y aura peut-être une fin de
crise sanitaire chez nous on aura de la
chance très bien vous en sortir et là on
vous dit les mesures que vous avez
utilisés sont exorbitantes
parce qu'il ya pas eu beaucoup de morts
ou pas autant qu'il y en a toujours trop
pas autant qu'on pouvait le redouter oui
mais ça on le sait maintenant on ne
savait pas avant moi je rappelle tout le
monde s'en souvient d'ailleurs le tout
ce témoin là il ya deux mois et demi on
pensait qu'on aurait possiblement une
catastrophe vrai que beaucoup plus des
modélisations à 500000 absolument donc
bon moi je veux bien aujourd'hui on
commence à se rassurer c'est très bien
ces modélisations n'ont pas été avérée
probalement d'ailleurs parce que le
confinement lequel est aussi faible de
discussions mais après c'est toujours
plus plus simple et c'est pas pour
diminuer la critique c'est pour situer
quand même le caractère compliqué de
décisions qui sont prises depuis
quelques quelques mois un autre
empressement c'est effectivement celui
de des confiné c'était même la question
posée en une du journal du dimanche et
hier
et si on allait plus vite la question
est posée par des parents d'élèves elle
est posée par les chefs d'entreprise par
les restaurateurs olivier ferrand a
répondu à cette impatience était ce
matin lors d'un déplacement à que je me
souvienne à argenteuil on l'écouté je
vous fait réagir
nous évaluons la situation au jour le
jour en fonction des indicateurs en
fonction aussi du niveau de saturation
de notre système de santé avec des gens
ici y compris des médecins qui vous
disent attention quand même attention
quand même
n'allons pas trop vite on a réussi à
gagner une bataille par l'effort de tous
une bataille qu'il était très difficile
de gagner on n'a pas encore gagné la
guerre donc vigilance et alors là vous
nous dites pareil qu'effectivement c'est
peut-être un peu facile de dire
maintenant qu'il faut des confits n'est
plus lui-même situe le cas des enfants
que vous évoquez il ya un sujet majeur
nous savons hélas c'est un savoir
certains ça c'est pas l'épidémiologie
c'est des sciences de la pédagogie et la
connaissance nous avons de la formation
et l'éducation
la sociologie ne permet de savoir cela
nous savons que les enfants qui ont raté
l'école pendant plusieurs semaines parce
qu'il fallait bien les protégés vont
avoir un retard qui selon le milieu
social sera pas rattrapé et ça va avoir
des conséquences probablement sur toute
leur vie et c'est des conséquences
négatives dans un pays comme la france
où l'école la diplomation un rôle si
important mon avis trop important mais
c'est un autre sujet ces enfants-là par
centaines de milliers on va avoir un
handicap à vie qui va les gêner
qui va les faire sortir plus vite du
système scolaire qui va les amener plus
vite vers les échecs scolaires regarde
toute une série de conséquences qui sont
dramatiques temps plus que là on est en
juin
il ya ensuite les vacances d'été donc
deux mois de plus c'est beaucoup trop
long
on sait mais on le sait depuis peu de
temps voyez un autre exemple moi ça va
frapper
on sait maintenant que les enfants sont
moins contagieux on pensait le contraire
il ya quelques semaines vient donc moi
je me dis quand on doit décider on vous
dit les spécialistes ils sont plus
contagieux ok donc on va laisser à
l'écart non ils sont - comptage et aux
gains de change d'avis bocquet donc ça
veut dire quoi c'est à dire que
maintenant au contraire moi je pense que
là dans la mesure où on sait cela sur
les enfants dans la mesure où la cerise
que leur retard scolaire qui va être
très coûteux pour eux et qu'on pourra
pas rattraper à tous les coups on a une
espèce de devoir d'organiser un retour à
l'école plus massif et plus rapide des
enfants et même alors je dis ça sans
avoir fait aucune étude de faisabilité
mais il me semble qu'on devrait
envisager de rallonger la période
scolaire pour compenser un peu
une semaine dix jours de plus par
rapport à ce qui avait été prévu
je dis ça encore une fois en toute
modestie parce que c'est toujours très
compliqué quand on pense à ces choses là
et de les rendre opérationnelles mais
l'idée de rallonger la période scolaire
ou d'eau voulons ne pas finir maintenant
est absolument essentiel pour que ces
enfants reviennent à l'école
réapprennent quelque chose de l'école y
compris d'ailleurs cette discipline
collective parce que sinon on en aura
perdu beaucoup
et là encore en matière d'école on le
sait c'est ainsi c'est naturel c'est pas
une anomalie
les familles qui vont bien s'occuper de
leurs enfants rattraperont ce retard
celles qui ne pourront pas pour diverses
raisons ne le rattrape auront pas donc
il y aura une injustice sociale
avez-vous trouvé les français docile
comme l'a dit bernard henri lévy dans le
livre qui va bientôt paraître et dont
quelques pages ont été publiés par le
journal du dimanche ce week end il a
parlé je le cite un de notre à urt
e-sante docilité à l'ordre sanitaire en
marche
ben je n'ai pas compris moi cette cette
remarque de bernard henri lévy sur les
hostilités
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire on nous
a tous annoncé des nouvelles terribles
un virus inconnu qui voulait de chine
on prend des mesures historiques partout
dans le monde on a été 4 milliards dans
le monde à être confinés les médecins
sont pas d'accord entre eux on sait pas
le traitement n'a bien sûr pas de vaccin
vous avez des cas dans vos entourage de
personnes plus ou moins proche mais qui
sont malades ce qui rend proche de la
mort d'autres qui meurent pas tout à
cause de l'âge ou d'une couleur visiter
apparente
bref qu'est ce qu'il faut faire sinon
être prudents et c'est une drôle d'idée
de se dire on va continuer
les norvégiens les suédois l'ont fait
ils ont fait ça et se doit ils ont fait
collectivement une sorte de nous on va
faire autrement on va pas confiné les
noirs ne s'est pas abattue là-bas
bizarrement la psychose mais maintenant
on est abattue sur notre pays maintenant
la colère gronde en suède puisque le
responsable en chef de la stratégie de
non déconfinement dit je me suis trompé
et il ya beaucoup de morts en plus il
est suédois sous
comptabilise le nombre de morts ils nous
donneront le vrai chiffre et ne sont pas
malhonnêtes mais ils ont des techniques
de comptabilisation qui sous-estiment
nombre de morts ils vont avoir beaucoup
et ils ont échoué sur un point clé qui
est qu'il n'ya que 7 % de suédois qui
ont les anticorps donc même la la la la
protection de groupes celle à laquelle
il aspirait avec cette stratégie tout à
fait singulière n'a pas été couronné de
succès donc c'est un échec sur toute la
ligne
ils n'ont même pas échappé à la crise
économique bien sûr puisque dans un
monde globalisé c'est tout le monde
s'arrête vous arrêter aussi par
définition donc voilà est-ce que c'est
du courage
est-ce qu'il fallait désobéir à ça
c'était c'était quand même un geste
citoyen nous nous sommes séparés pour
rester proche
nous avons cessé de nous serrer la main
pour rester amis c'est à l'envers que
tout ça fonctionne c'est pas parce que
nous sommes devenus hostiles ou défiant
les à l'égard des autres nous voulions
nous protéger mutuellement
c'est un acte de production collective
après c'est difficile c'est la première
fois que ça se fait donc c'est on peut
pas faire tomber sur une décision
inédite face à un événement inédit
je dirais tout le savoir que nous aurons
quelque part parce qu'il y en a pas y a
rien du tout et on ne sait même pas moi
je sais pas par exemple si ce virus
j'en sais rien moi ce que je lis je dis
beaucoup là dessus et en plus moi j'ai
tout de suite vu qu'il y avait un
problème très très tôt donc je suis pas
du tout surpris par l'ampleur de tout ça
mais si on m'explique moi parce que
c'est pas ma partie encore une fois que
le virus commis il semble circuler dans
le monde il ya 100 milles cap par jour
dans le monde
cent mille nouveaux cas par jour
pascontent est plus aussi dans fait à
100 milles voka par joe bon le virus il
va vivre
il va vivre danis faire à l'autre on va
le revoir à cet automne et en hiver ou
pas s'il revient qu'est ce qu'on fait on
découvre maintenant on sait on des
confits non confine pas puisqu'on nous
dit que on est docile ou qu'il faut pas
le faire et puis on voit ce qui se passe
dans le métro mais des 10 millions de
voyageurs par jour
en ile de france donc c'est beaucoup de
je trouve de ces considérations
ordinaire pour une situation
extraordinaire cette sévérité en tous
cas à l'égard du gouvernement et de la
gestion de cette crise pourrait se
ressentir dans les urnes c'est une
transition pour en venir là un autre
sujet sur lequel j'aimerais vous amener
c'est le second tour des municipales qui
approche le premier tour a été
défavorable déjà à la république en
marche est plutôt favorable à l air la
droite on termine avec un long cycle de
défaites nous a dit françois baroin
président de la mfr cette interview
accordée à nos confrères du journal du
dimanche c'est ce qu'il est un peu
optimiste puisqu'il a raison d'être
confiants alors là aussi d'ailleurs je
m'entends répondre à vos questions et
mais là aussi ça donne l'air un peu
comme ça ça va donner un air un peu
curieux mais la série de mes réponses
mais là aussi je me dis regardons les
choses factuellement les élections
municipales dans un contexte en général
et encore plus dans le contexte actuel
qui est très bouleversée je parle pas du
coc vida mais je parle de la
globalisation la crise historique que
nous vivons etc
les élections municipales c'est un peu
l'élection qui pour chacun d'entre nous
est celle du petit monde à soi notre
commune paris sert à pas ça va peut-être
jouer dans le même sens d'ailleurs
et qu'est ce qu'on fait là on dit je
vote pour moi quand même pour ma ville
de bromont quartier et mon quotidien
quotidien et c'est donc là j'aime j'aime
bien ne pas changer ça c'est pas là
qu'on fait des expériences veut dire
qu'il ya pas de changement mais la norme
c'est la reconduction par la destitution
ce qui est le cas au niveau national par
contre donc si vous n'avez pas d'élu
vous pouvez pas avoir de nouveau puisque
la norme c'est la reconduction la france
la république en marche n'avait pas
d'élus pas beaucoup on verra ce qui se
passe à lyon
donc il pouvait pas en gagner puisqu'il
fallait sortir ce qui est en place et
c'est précisément le plus compliqué les
mairies était aux mains du ps et dlr
parce que le précédent scrutin s'était
2014 avant le grand bouleversement donc
assez logiquement les verts et le ps
vont retrouver des élus donc vous n'y
voyez pas du tout une forme de victoire
de la droite ou une sortie de crise de
cette droite très mal en point depuis
quelques années potentiellement une
victoire du christ d'un christian jacob
et de son son côté rassembler alors il
ne démérite pas un ni ni françois baroin
que d'une personne éminente ni froid ni
monsieur jacob s'est arrêtée de dlr qui
panse les plaies d'un parti qui a été
éliminé du second tour de la
présidentielle
or sélection de ce parti c'est les
hérité du gaullisme mais mais mais mais
simplement non ça n'est pas là que ça va
se prouver je comprends qu'on le dise
pour mettre du baume au coeur des
militants mais on verra combien il y
aura deux villes qui resteront à droite
au sortir de cette de ces élections sans
doute que la plupart seront reconduites
de ces villes ou à gauche c'est pareil
pour le ps staff est symétrique
mais on sait aujourd'hui que les l air
comme le ps sont très faible
politiquement fait pourquoi parce que ce
qui fait revenir une force politique
c'est pas des élections municipales avec
les vainqueurs les sortants qui sont
réélus c'est les idées politiques
c'est un nouveau modèle une série de
propositions portées par des leaders qui
tirent les militants et puis les
électeurs surtout ça aujourd'hui
bien que la droite comme le ps ne manque
pas de personnes de qualité on ne le
voit pas du tout ni idées nouvelles
n'y figurent qui véritablement se mettre
en avant
donc françois baroin a promis de
clarifier sa position à l'automne veut
c'est peut-être un élément là qui
permettra aux électeurs de droite se
dire ah là ça me ça me parle samba etc
il faudra aussi des idées on voit bien
que vous avez bertrand est aussi un acte
entêtantes et où valérie pécresse ou qui
sait pas ce que c'est bien sûr pas
fermée mais c'est encore tout à fait
alors ce qu'on peut dire simplement je
termine là dessus et c'est que si la
droite avait perdu ses villes c'était
fini si le ps par des taux de ces villes
c'est nul c'est fini bien sûr un dock
s'est heureusement ce n'est pas la fin
de ces parties là et ça veut dire aussi
que le clivage gauche droite en tout cas
résiste au niveau local ben c'est la
république en marche n'a pas été une
vague qui a déferlé sur les
municipalités je crois que le niveau
local et c'est ce qui est ce qu'ils
disent ou le clivage gauche droite parce
qu'on ne vote pas pour un maire parce
qu'il est de droite n'est pas ce qu'on
dit qu'il a bien fait son boulot ou
je pourrais dire une mère pour faire un
peu parité mais en fait il a très peu
malheureusement les femmes mères vous le
savez je crois qu'il ya 10 15 % c'est
très peu c'est un problème
les conseils municipaux sont paritaires
par les mairies donc c'est plutôt des
hommes c'est pas parce qu'ils sont de
droite ou de gauche qu'on va revoter
pour eux ça parce qu'on dit ils ont bien
fait leur boulot d'une part et d'autre
part ce qu'il y a comme opposition me
rassure pas donc je reconduis droite ou
gauche monfils je reconduis les maires
qui ont bien fait leur boulot d'ailleurs
pendant cette crise aussi les français
se sont rendus compte de la force du
local peut être d'ailleurs au détriment
de l'état central est ce que pour vous
c'est aussi cette crise l'échec d'un
état jacobin victoire de l'état
girondins est ce qu on pourrait le voir
comme cela aussi
en tout cas moi je crois qu'il y à un
échec lancinant de l'état jacobin
anciens ça fait pas six mois se fait pas
d'eux en aide de camp qui datent
probablement des années 70 de ce moment
où on est sorti des trente glorieuses et
on aurait dû comprendre qu'il fallait
organiser autrement le pays on à rester
dans un modèle qui avait très bien
fonctionné c'est pas tout bien tout mal
l'état jacobin il a été très efficace en
france pour reconstruire après 1945 pour
accompagner les trente glorieuses pour
les progrès matériel c'était formidable
la sécurité sociale etc c'est pas ça la
question c'est après un modèle qui
marche c'est pas un modèle qui marche
toujours il faut toujours c'est par
définition non et là on est resté est
d'ailleurs question au ps et au plr
qu'est ce qu'ils font avec l'état
jacobin parce que là ils ont été au
gouvernement longtemps
ils ont préservé où ils ont essayé de
décentraliser ils l'ont renforcé les uns
et les autres ils n'ont jamais vraiment
remis en cause cela est aujourd'hui
cette crise là elle est encore plus
visible
il n'en peut plus cet état jacobin il
étouffe ses propres prétentions il
réussit presque rien de ce qu'il
entreprend et donc là c'est un vrai là
on l'a on fait de la cogestion de
déconfinement avec les maires très au
courant très au fait c'est le bon niveau
efficaces s'ils savent de quoi ils
parlent pour les écoles des mères c'est
indispensable
ils connaissent les classes ils
connaissent les mètres carrés enfin ils
savent tous du détail ils sont en lien
avec le préfet ça marche préfet ce n'est
pas pour me
jacobin et donc on a une réorganisation
à faire mais de manière non pas
exceptionnel parce que c'est une crise
mais de manière beaucoup plus
organisationnel structurelles pour
effectivement partagé le pouvoir sait
pas si on peut encore dire décentralisée
parce qu'on a tellement dit qu'on n'y
croit plus mais partager ce pouvoir avec
des détenus et moi je dirais aussi non
seulement des élus des territoires mais
aussi des des forces vives les
entreprises
le monde associatif il faut partager le
pouvoir à différents niveaux avec avec
différentes institutions il les partage
tellement le pouvoir que emmanuel macron
consulte tous azimuts cherche des idées
des solutions pour la préco vide il a
envoyé une lettre au président du sénat
de l'assemblée nationale et du lycée the
pour qu'ils soumettent des contributions
d'ici à un mois
et la démarche est un peu surpris au
sénat aussi certains ont dit en off
comme on dit le sénat ne travaille pas
pour l'elysée comment comment vous voyez
cela des institutions qui ont du mal
aussi a peut-être travailler ensemble et
cette démarche d'emmanuel mac ont envoyé
une lettre de demande est là franchement
je savais pas ça moi cette réaction mais
honnêtement vous êtes le sénat vous
demandez la décentralisation
vous demandez le giron 10 mhz le chef de
l'état jacobin vous écris donnez moi des
idées vous dites je travaille pas pour
vous mais ça ce qu'on veut au contraire
ont saisi la balle au bond saisi la
perche l'envoûtant si on vous dit est-ce
que vous avez des idées si vous en avez
mais partageaient les ça fera vivre le
débat on va avancer on va trouver des
solutions il y aura des compromis parce
que la politique c'est des solutions
c'est aussi beaucoup de compromis on va
arriver dans le vif du sujet desquels
vous prêt à faire vous vraiment vous les
élus locaux parce que les élus locaux
ils veulent du pouvoir mais pas toujours
des responsabilités qui vont avec ça
compliqué dans la voiture je veux bien
m'occuper de ça mais à condition que
s'il ya un problème je sois pas
responsable mais non donc il faut
arriver à trouver un juste équilibre
mais ça c'est des choses qu'on rencontre
assez souvent dans nos sociétés je
parlais de consultation de la part des
médiums la cour vous aussi vous avez été
consultés par emmanuel macron on
l'apprend dans le jdd d'hier vous avez
été invité à déjeuner le 28 mai dernier
alors qu'on nous donne évidemment de d
la teneur des propos mais vous le sentez
dans quel état d'esprit justement dans
une recherche de solutions et après tout
le monde y compris des présidentes sim
tant que je peux faire un petit
témoignage là dessus allez-y bien sûr
c'est la première fois que je suis à
l'elysée à un déjeuner de travail avec
un président on va à l'elysée parfois
c'est rarement pour un vrai travail
c'est juste la méthode il fallait qu'on
donne par avance sur un sujet une note
moi j'ai donné une note de 5 pages
chacun a fait la même chose on était
quatre on a fait chacun la même chose
sur un sujet différent mais on m'a
demandé de réfléchir sur les de
localiser les relocalisations et
l'europe
je vais sujet associe les deux convainc
pas chacun a fait sur un sujet différent
une note avant le déjeuner une semaine
avant enfin l'art en une semaine avant
et vous aviez des douars la note est élu
quand on est arrivé on a déjeuné pendant
deux heures on a des jeunes et un repas
andine hermes est rapide mais on a bossé
on a discuté sur les notes pendant deux
heures
ça c'est quand même ça m'a frappé voilà
j'ai pas expérience à faire non plus que
moi ça m'a frappé c'est ma seule
expérience déjeuner avec un président
donc ça m'a frappée je sais pas si tout
le monde faisait comme ça ça c'est la
première remarque ensuite c'est l'idée
aux faux que on est à un moment
historique
s'il ya des personnes qui pensent avoir
travaillé avoir fait des expertises
avoir fait des idées parce que c'est pas
le moment de les partager et partager
avec ceux qui peuvent agir c'est le rôle
du président du sénat du sénat le
modeste directeur d'un think tank que je
suis on travaille en ce moment j'ai
lancé une série d'études sur les
relocalisations en france et en europe
un plan ambitieux de travail que nous
avons que nous sommes en train de
réaliser la moindre des choses c'est
gratuit ce que nous faisons en fait on
n'est pas payé pour ça on le met sur les
sites on le partage avec qui le veut la
moindre des choses si on me propose d'en
parler c'est que je le fais au contraire
c'est formidable on peut valoriser un
travail qui est fait est exactement pour
ça et que vous apportiez vouziers merci
infiniment signé d'avoir participé à cet
entretien